اما روسيا فحملت كلا من النت والولايات
المتحده المسؤوليه عن حادث سقوط صاروخ في
الاراضي الفولتيه وقد المتحدث باسم
الكرملين ديمتري بيسكوف ان الامريكيين
يقولون انه لو لم يكن هناك صراع ما سقط
الصاروخ واضاف ان السبب كل شيء هو الناتو
والولايات المتحده
وكان الرئيس الامريكي قال ان الصاروخ
اطلقته دفاعات الجويه الاخرانيه لكن
المسؤولين الامريكيين راوا ان المسؤوليه
تقع في نهايه على عتيق روسيا لانها
المسؤوله عن الحرب وفق تعبيرهم
معنا من وارسو مراسل الجزيره محمد البقالي
ومن موسكو معنى مراسله الجزيره سلام خضر
وسنبدا معك محمد البقالي
وتطور الموقف في بولندا من حادثه
الصاروخين اللذين ساقطاع عند المنطقه
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا في ضوء التاكيد
الاوكراني ان مصدرهما موسكو وتاكيد
الامريكي والبولندي
[تصفيق]
وليس من روسيا وانه لم يكن هناك استهداف
المتعمد للاراضي الهولنديه هذه التصريحات
صدرت على لساني اكثر من مسؤول والحقيقه
يمكن ان نقول ان هذه التصريحات قد اثار
ارتياحا كبيرا في بولندا في كثير وفي معظم
بل وفي كل دول الحلف نيته لماذا لان اي
تاكيدات غير ذلك تشير بان استهداف كان
متعمدا هذا يعني تطورا كثيرا على مستوى
الحرب وادافع في اتجاهات ربما لا احد يرغب
فيها ان تذهب فيها همم ربما التمدد الحرب
فنيته على الاقل في هذه المرحله وبالتالي
يمكن ان نقول ان هذه الخلاصات هي جاءت
متوافقه مع ما كانت تتمناه بولندا
ولكن رغم ذلك فهذا لا يمنع بالنسبه
تقع في نهايه المطاف على روسيا تقع ولا
روسيا لان وفقا للرئيس البولندي ورئيس
الوزراء ووزير الدفاع فان هذه الحرب التي
تسبب فيها هي روسيا وبالتالي فهي تتحمل
مسؤوليه كل تبيعاتها وان هذه هذين ما كان
ليسقط على الاراضي البولنديه لولا هذه
الحرب على كل حال يمكن ان نقول هناك الان
عوده الى حاله الهدوء عوده الى حاله ما
قبل سقوط هذين الصاروخين ولكن ايضا مع
احت- طب ما تتوقعاتهم بان الاسود يمكن ان
يحدث في اي لحظه على كل حال
يستشهدون بان التاريخ يحمل شواهد بان كثير
من الحروب اندلعت في كثير من الاحيان
بسببي ضربته طائشه او خاطئه او ان
احتمالات حدوث هذه الاخطاء قد تكررها وهذا
ما يثيره مزيدا من القلق ال- انعكاس ذلك
المباشر هنا على مستوى على بولندا على
مستوى العسكري مزيد من حاجتي والقوات
ومزيد من الحاله من حاله التاهب وايضا
مزيد من التسليح اعلن وزير الدفاع البارحه
بان الجيش البولندي سيتم تزويده بمزيد من
المضادات هذا بالاضافه الى وجود وهذا
الامر منذ بدايه هذه الحرب وجود منظومات
صواريخ متطوره سواء منها الامريكيه او
البريطانيه بولندا على هذا المستوى
الاحتمالات تمددي الحرب لان هذه
الاحتمالات تبدو ان يمكن ان تحدث عن
قاصدين او عن غيرها وعلى المستوى السياسي
والديكم راسي تتواصل المشاورات على وجه
الخصوص ومع الحلفاء
معنى سلام اذا الموقف الروسي الذي ظل
ثابتا منذ البدايه ان هذا الصاروخ ليس
هجوما هل يعني كما اشار محمد هل عاده الام
الى ما قبل سقوط هذا الصاروخ بالنسبه لها
وهي تتابع هذه المجريات وانعكاسات ذلك
ايضا سياسيا
بالنسبه لموسكو كما ذكرت محمد متمسكه
بموقفها منذ الاعلان عن سقوط صاروخ داخل
الاراضي البولنديه مسقطره منذ بدايه ما
تسميها العمليه العسكريه او الحرب في
اوكرانيا ترى بان الغرب وبالتحديد حلف
الناتو والولايات المتحده هم المسؤولان عن
تصعيد الامور بشكل خطير تلقي بالله ما
عليهما على اكثر من مستوى على المستوى
العسكري تقول بان التدريبات التي تقوم بها
النيته للجيش الاوكراني ورفع مستويات
التسليح لدى الجيش الاوكراني همم ليس سوى
وسيله لاطاله امد الصراع امس سمعنا
تصريحات اقوى من ذلك هناك المتحدث باسم
همم لجنه الخارجيه في الدومه الروسي اتهم
بشكل صريح الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والنيتو بانه ما يدفعان الامور باتجاه حرب
عالميه ثالثه هذا على مستوى السياسي ايضا
هناك همم تصريحات لافته كانت من الجانب
الروسي الخارجيه الروسيه استدعت همم
القائم بالاعمال البولنديه مساء يوم امس
وابلغته رساله واضحه بحسب بيان صدر عن
الخارجيه ابلغت الخارجيه الروسيه
الدبلوماسيه البولنديه بانه على وورسو
التوقف عن اللحاق بالغرب فيما يتعلق
بالتصريحات المتوتره بحسب بيان الخارجيه
ودعت الخارجيه الروسيه الى التهدئه والى
اجراء تحقيقات ميدانيه شفافه وقالت ان هذه
التحقيقات من شانها ان تكشف ان الموقف
الروسي هو الموقف السليم منذ اليوم الاول
حين اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان مصدر
الصاروخ ليس همم القوات الروسيه وهو حتى
لا يندرج في ايطاليا الذخيره او ذخائر
والصواريخ التي يستخدمها الجيش الروسي
محمد
شكرا جزيلا لك اشكر محمد البقالي ايضا
منور شكرا لكما